[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So, our first panel is
on tattoos and perfume,
and it will be
introduced and moderated
by our beloved Professor
Diana Sorensen.
Our colleagues
here know her well.
But again is James
Rothenberg Professor
of Romance Languages and
Literatures and Professor
of Comparative
Literature at Harvard
and until recently--
and, of course,
a very distinguished scholar
of Latin American literature.
Until recently, she was dean
of the humanities at Harvard,
and I would say probably in
my 30 years of experience
in universities, probably the
most beloved administrator
I've ever encountered.
So, Professor Sorensen.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Hisa.
I remember very fondly the
beginning of our conversations
about this
conference, and I want
to say that seeing what you
did with those early thoughts,
which were aspirational
and somewhat messy--
seeing what it's turned into
is a very real pleasure.
Our panel this morning
is focused on two areas
that the Academy needs to pursue
more consistently and more
deeply.
So I trust that our conversation
this morning will give us
a full sense of
what work could be
done furthering
our understanding
of both tattoos and scent.
And as Professor Peters just
marvelously stated just now,
I want to have us
think about the extent
to which every medium
reorganizes embodiment.
And here, we're looking at skin.
Skin will be the
medium through which
scent and tattoos are inscribed,
if one could use that word.
That comes from my own
textual background.
So you have the
speakers' bios, so I
don't want to take
time away from hearing
their presentations.
I simply want to say they
will be relatively brief.
Then we'll have a
short conversation,
and then there will be time
for questions and answers
from all of you.
About Chandler Burr,
I want to just point
to two really fascinating
and important books--
one of 2003, The
Emperor of Scent,
about the whole mystery of
the obsession with perfume,
and one of 2008 that's
called The Perfect Scent.
And it deals with the industry
in both New York and in Paris.
Afterwards, we will
hear the presentation
of Dominique Holmes, who is
a London-based artist, who's
got one important book of
2013 called The Painted Lady:
the art of tattooing
the female body.
And I'm eagerly
awaiting a book that's
expected for 2020 with the
preliminary title, Painted
Ones.
And it includes, as
well, an exhibition.
So I would like to invite
Dominique and Chandler to join
me up here.
[APPLAUSE]
- Am I here?
- You're there.
- I was told I'm somewhere.
- So, I believe you--
- Do I launch into it?
- Please.
- OK, so, ready, guys?
OK.
So, what's interesting,
I was the--
I met this guy in the
Gare du Nord in 1998.
I'm a journalist.
I actually have a background
in Japanese political economy
and Asian studies.
And I was doing some
work-- you can go, yeah.
Hand them out.
Thank you.
Now, this is the first work
that we're going to smell, OK?
I got into this, and I
really sort of fell into it.
I met this guy in
the Gare du Nord.
He is an expert of perfume, and
he was absolutely brilliant.
And I wound up writing
a book about him.
He's a scientist, and he was
working on a biophysical theory
of how we smell, because
we don't actually
know how we smell.
We don't understand
how it works.
But at the same time, the
reason he was working on it is--
don't you have-- oh,
you have a blotter.
We don't think about
the art form that it--
scent as a medium.
Scent is one of the
most important mediums,
artistic mediums, in the world.
And it is unrecognized.
And it's extraordinary, I
would posit to you that scent
is a medium that is right now
in the stage of recognition
by the Academy, gallerists,
museums, the public,
as photography was in
the 1950s and '60s.
Photography was viewed
as being this craft,
this interesting thing
that, basically, you
had a photograph,
you had some reality,
and it was about as artistic
as looking in the mirror
or seeing somebody else
reflected in a glass.
It was just not recognized
as artistic at all.
And then we came to
understand that, actually,
every photograph is a lie,
the lie in the best sense.
Cindy Sherman-- there was this
wonderful biography of her,
and she was asked
why-- because she
used to be a painter, and
then she started photography.
And she was asked, well,
why did you switch?
And she sort of
thought about it,
and she said, um,
I don't know, I
guess it was easier to
lie with the camera.
And all art is artificial,
in the best sense.
It has to be.
Because it has to
have a mind behind it
that has a point of
view that has a desire
to create a reality
to present something
to you, to force you to
perceive the world in the way
that it wants you to.
All right?
Now, this is one of the
most extraordinary works
of olfactory art in the
past 20 years or even more.
This is a neo-romanticist
work by an artist
named Pierre [? Nugrin, ?]
who is brilliant, brilliant.
And it is a--
it's a relatively recent
work, as a matter of fact.
I should know the--
I'm forgetting the
year right now.
But it came out, and it
was, I think, something--
I think that this
is the greatest--
an extraordinary
masterpiece in several ways.
First of all, as with
everything, paint--
by the way, scent is the
equal of paint and clay
and music and
architecture and film.
It is absolutely
the equal of those.
And it is also understood
in this highly-developed
vocabulary that we have for art.
It fits in my purpose.
I created the Department
of Olfactory Art
at the Museum of Arts
and Design in New York.
Before that, I was the
New York Times art critic,
and this was the medium that
works created in this, OK?
So I think that we
really need to understand
this is as a work.
It fits into the schools of
art as we understand them.
Do you smell how--
if you know anything
about romanticism,
everything the
Romanticists believed,
both in literature and music
and the other mediums--
and those are very
different mediums--
but romanticism is
represented in them.
Not every school is
represented in every medium.
In this case, it was mostly
literature and music.
But this is a work
of romanticism.
Romanticists rejected
rationality emphatically.
They rejected thought as the
source of logic and rationale
and these other sorts of
things as a way to find truth.
And this, I find,
is non-structured.
It is not abstract
expressionist,
because it has very, very
specific real-world references.
Do you smell the certain things?
There is a-- and I hate--
and we apply such
a poor vocabulary
to this medium, this
artistic medium,
because it is not
recognized as such yet.
And we reduce it
to "notes" and sort
of stupid things like that.
It's a moronic-- well,
what are the notes?
Well, I mean, Jesus,
look at a Rembrandt.
Well, what are the colors?
Oh, here's black,
and here's red.
Oh, there's a little yellow.
Who gives a damn?
It's a Rembrandt.
You don't wear the color--
you don't look at the colors,
you look at the painting.
You look at the work.
You do not wear the notes or--
and this is the correct way
to say it-- raw materials.
OK?
You wear the work of art,
and you wear it on skin.
And it's made for skin.
As a matter of fact,
we were talking,
and this is something that's
very interesting, that I'm
paired with Dominique, because
this is the only other art
medium that is created to be
worn on an extraordinarily
weird canvas, human skin.
OK?
Now, this is wonderful.
Gender-- I read
about this a lot.
Look, gender is very, very
specific in this medium.
Said art was never gendered.
It is ridiculous.
Perfumers-- olfactory artists--
hate it.
They hate it.
They're not allowed to
talk about it overtly,
because they basically
work for corporations
who want to sell this--
scent is a medium that
is hugely colonized by--
damn it, how much
time do I have?
- You have-- I can tell you.
You're left with
five and a half.
- Five and a half.
OK, thank you.
Well, keep me honest.
So I'm just going to
say this, and we're
going to do the next one.
They hate it-- you know, as
one of the greatest olfactory
artists, Jean-Claude
Ellena, said to me--
in private, but
now I'll out him--
he said, what about music?
He said, is Bartok for men
and Beethoven for women?
Is Radiohead for women
and the Beatles for men?
I mean, it would-- it's
ridiculous on its face.
So why do we do it with this?
For one very, very
specific reason--
post-war, one of the things
that American companies wanted
to do--
perfume is one of the greatest
ways-- along with film,
by the way.
Film is another medium
that's usually colonized
by corporate interests.
Warner Brothers, Paramount,
Fox, 20th Century Fox, so what?
Disney.
And that's fine.
That's fine, and there are great
works of art that are actually
made by these companies.
Toy Story made a billion,
two billion dollars,
whatever it is.
It's the most commercial
film, in a way,
that you've ever seen.
It is a work of art.
It's extraordinary
at the same time, OK?
This was made to make money.
All art is created
to make money, OK?
Let's be clear about that.
But this, this is gorgeous.
After the war, you
wanted to make money.
It's an incredibly commercial--
lucrative, sorry, lucrative
medium.
The only reason that you had--
suddenly perfume was
gendered is that they wanted
to sell perfume to a culture,
to men in a culture that
had no cultural history of
scent as an art, which is,
of course, American culture.
And so what they did
was they divided it
into masculines and feminines.
And they were
basically-- if it said
"for him," that is only
giving heterosexual men
psycho-emotional
permission to wear scent.
It's the only reason it exists.
Next one?
OK, so this is--
notice I don't want
to get into the--
I'm going to tell you
later, but I don't
want to get into it right now.
I don't want to talk
about the brand.
I don't want to talk about
the creative director, who
in this case is actually
very, very important, OK?
Please keep these separate.
Remember that you're
smelling the second one.
Put the first one in your
pocket or somewhere else.
You're welcome to
keep it, but I just
don't want you to confuse it.
OK, now this-- do you
sense how different this
is as a work of art?
We have gone from Rachmaninoff
to, if you will, Philip Glass.
- Yes.
- This is a work of minimalism.
It presents as a whole.
The other-- the work of
romanticism, it's huge.
You saw.
It was going in every
single direction.
It was speaking loudly.
It was singing.
There was texture to it.
It was absolutely extraordinary.
OK?
This is something-- minimalism
as a philosophy really
was not just simplicity.
Simplicity was part of it.
But minimalism,
philosophically, really
was an effort-- how
much time do I have?
- Two and a half.
- OK, we're fine.
So, minimalism was a way of
presenting just the material
and the beauty of the material.
And this is a
combination of both.
This is a presentation
of the materials,
which, again, I'm not
going to get into,
because it doesn't matter.
Maybe it does matter.
One of the materials
in this case--
maybe it's legitimate now.
I just hate it so much that I
want to get away from it, OK?
So I'm being extremist.
I'm taking an
extremist position.
If you look at a work of
architecture, Renzo Piano's--
the New York Times, for
example, where I worked.
I mean, it's very interesting,
the materials that he used.
And you could talk
about the materials,
but only in the service of
understanding the overall work
of architecture.
So to understand this,
there's a molecule in here
that is very interesting.
They're called-- they're
like, three benzyl, four
hexyl, whatever the hell it is.
Sorry about that.
But you know, they're
called lactones--
lactic acid milk.
Do you smell that?
Do you smell the milky quality?
It's a very, very interesting
presentation of it.
I think that it's also
sort of-- there's sort
of a wood aspect to it.
One minute.
Let's go out with the last one.
But it is as if you were
playing one note. (SINGING) La.
And maybe there's
some more to it.
Is the first work masculine,
the second work feminine?
Again, ridiculous,
absolutely ridiculous.
It makes no sense, and
it denigrates the medium
to think of it in those terms.
Now, this is one
of my favorite--
- Yes!
- --works of olfactory art.
Isn't this freaking great?
Becky told me I
can't use the F-word.
But it's freaking great.
Isn't that amazing?
- It's glorious.
- So, this is truly--
this is interesting, because
this is a work of neo,
if you will--
no, I think it's best understood
as a work of hyperrealism.
It is a realist portraiture.
And I'm actually going to
ask you, what is this in--
this is an olfactory photograph.
What is it a photograph of?
Lilac, exactly.
Yeah.
The artist is-- oh
my gosh, I forgot.
The artist of the
Dries van Noten--
who the hell?
Now I can't remember
the perfumer, who is--
aw, Frederick let us down.
He didn't put the
name of the artist.
Now I can't remember.
I think-- I'm going
to go out on a limb.
I think it was Bruno
Jovanovic, I think.
God help me if I'm wrong.
Bruno is very, very interesting.
He's a relatively young artist.
But this is just extraordinary.
And this artist is one of
the great, great olfactory
artists of the late 20th,
early 21st centuries.
Her name is Olivia
Giacobetti, and she
has created here a work
of hyperrealism-- realism
because you can tell
that it's lilac.
But the way that it's
presented is in, again,
a way that a
hyperrealist painter
would present that visually,
or a hyperrealist photograph.
You think of Mapplethorpe's--
oh, how much time do I have?
Am I over?
- Yes.
- OK.
I'm over.
So, last comment--
Mapplethorpe's flowers,
those are not just flowers.
You see a flower.
You see so much more,
the symbolism of this.
This is extraordinary.
It is not just real.
It is not just immediate.
It is hyperreal.
It is something that's
over-- it is an experience
of the object-- the very
specific object in this case,
which the others were not--
that forces you to reconceive
reality, like all art should.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Can you make these last all day?
- The length of time that
a work of olfactory art
lasts, it depends on its
composition, its construction--
and the technical
mastery of the artist.
- Well, thank you again
so much, Chandler.
And now let me turn it over to
Dominique Holmes and tattoos.
- When modern tattooing
started to emerge
in the Western culture
in the late 19th century,
it was predominantly men
who were getting tattooed.
But this was pretty much just
down to the greater autonomy
they were afforded.
But the early 20th
century saw women
such as Jesse Knight and Maud
Stevens breaking the mold
and becoming very much respected
collectors and tattooers
in their own right.
The 1920s signified the
first significant shift
in the demographic of
the tattooed individual,
but also, significantly,
the first example of
tattoos being used as
a political statement.
The rise of the
suffragette movement
saw many society women
seeking out tattoos
as a way to symbolize
their crusade.
And they would wear them
very proudly as a mark
of their rebellion and
their independence.
And this impact that they
had led to tattoos becoming
much more popular
amongst both men
and women of all
social backgrounds,
especially as tattoos
develop these very
romantic and
patriotic connotations
throughout the war.
However, the 1960s saw
a very dramatic shift
in the attitudes
towards tattoos.
The growing association
of tattooing
with gang culture in
the criminal underworld
led to an extreme
masculinization
of the aesthetic.
And around the same time, an
alarming hepatitis outbreak
combined with this
and really sent
tattooing underground,
where it became synonymous
with the misfits of society.
But then, what we see
again, the emergence
of the sexual revolution and
the women's liberation movement
led to nonconformist women
of all social and political
backgrounds looking
for ways to dismantle
the preconceived
ideas of femininity.
And what better
way to do this than
by marking your
body with something
which had come to represent the
height of extreme masculinity?
In 1970, Janis
Joplin very publicly
declared that the tattoo
she wears on her wrist
was a mark of
women's liberation.
Now, her artist, Lyle Tuttle,
who's very, very well-known,
well-respected
tattooer, he later
went on to describe
how the number of women
he tattooed following
on from Joplin
increased so dramatically
that he actually credited her
with the shift in the
acceptance of tattoos
within mainstream culture.
I'm going to start to introduce
you to some of my clients
as we go, as well.
The anti-feminist backlash
that arose in the '80s
saw the media start to promote
a very demure, submissive,
and passive appearance
and expression for women.
And this very
hyperfeminine appearance
became the
aspirational aesthetic.
And alongside this, the
rebellious nature of tattooing
and the connotations that it
had with these revolutionary,
strong, rebellious
women saw it really
become the antithesis of
this expected behavior.
And what we've
seen is this stigma
it was given has been
very hard to shift,
even all these years later.
As we entered the
21st century, the rise
in the mainstream appreciation,
I suppose, of tattooing
has seen it become more popular
than it's ever been before.
A study conducted by the Dalia
Research Center in Germany
last year has found
that more than a third
of adults across the world are
now believed to be tattooed.
And, interestingly,
for the first time,
women actually outnumber men.
But the study also found
that women are almost twice
as likely to feel and to
receive judgmental and negative
comments and attitudes about
their tattoos than men.
These lists are examples of
words used to describe tattoos,
either for men or for women, on
a very basic internet search.
Now, these extreme contrasts
depict the gendering
of tattoo and tattoo
imagery that we've
seen emerge alongside
its surge in popularity.
But the words are also
very much synonymous
with our society's
expectations on the behaviors
of the two binary genders.
When we think about the
toughness and the strength
and the rebellion that are
associated with tattooing,
these are also things
that are associated
with aspirational male behavior.
And so, as we've
seen, tattoos have
been a very welcomed part of
male culture for generations.
But these words and
these ideas very much
oppose expected standards of
behavior projected onto women.
And so what we see is
for women, every tattoo
acts as a political statement,
whether intentional or not.
And this is why they've
become so embraced as a way
to reject these gendered
expectations projected
onto them.
Now I'm going to take you
back to the 1990s for a moment
and back to the growing trend
amongst women for lower back
tattoos.
Now, it's unknown exactly when
the phrase was first coined,
but this style of
tattooing would go on
to be better-known
as the tramp stamp.
Now, this offensive term and
the many other equally sexist
and derogatory alternatives
that you can see-- this
is a list from Urban Thesaurus.
And I've actually
had to cut it down,
because there were so
many, and some of them
were actually, I felt, too
offensive to put up there.
But this is an example of the
slut shaming and the misogyny
that is directed towards women
who choose to be tattooed.
Two separate studies
carried out in 2004 and 2013
both found that tattooed
women are perceived
to be more sexually promiscuous
than their untattooed
counterparts.
This imbalance in the social
perceptions and acceptance
of men and women with tattoos
runs very much parallel
with the way that our
patriarchal culture
treats the two binary genders.
As we've seen,
historically, tattooed women
represent the rebellious
and the revolutionary.
And for the patriarchy,
there's nothing
that they fear more than
an angry, strong woman.
As women are constantly battling
with the beauty standards that
are imposed upon them by
the media and by society,
we're starting to see
tattoos as a tool that
can be used to redefine these
conventional ideals and a way
to form our own visions
and definitions of what
it means to be female.
For myself and for many
female-identifying and
female-presenting individuals
in the queer community,
tattoos have become an important
part of our appearance, which
we formulate and we utilize
to deconstruct the beauty
standards that have been
conditioned, really,
by and for the male gaze.
And in doing so, we can
form new definitions,
I suppose, away from the
heteronormative ideals
of femininity.
But equally, women
are increasingly
utilizing the political and
the masculine connotations
associated with
tattoos, but doing so
without necessarily
losing their femininity
and losing their
female appearance.
Many of my clients choose
traditionally feminine designs
and wear them almost
like a kind of jewelry
as a way to enhance
their female form.
And this is actually reminiscent
of the ancient Egyptians,
for whom the women
would adorn their skin
with decorative patterns very
reminiscent of the jewelry
they wore.
And it was very much
considered a sign of beauty
and of strength.
But either way,
what we're seeing
is, it's actually the rebellious
act of tattooing in itself
which women are using
to really break down
these outdated
ideas of femininity.
People often assume that I
tattoo more women than men.
And it's quite a lazy
assumption based, primarily,
on the aesthetic
of my work, which
is considered delicate and
intricate and traditionally
feminine.
But actually, my client base
covers all gender identities
fairly evenly.
And so what this
demonstrates in itself
is that it's also quite
possible to subvert this idea
that a tattoo must be a
masculine accessory just
through the choice of
design that is worn.
I know I'm running out of time,
so I'm going to try and get
through this quickly.
My client James finds
that his tattoos
are referred to as
feminine and girly simply
because of the subject
matter of the tattoos.
But to him, they're
actually a true reflection
of his own perceived
gender identity, which
is that of a young
man who connects
very much with the feminine
aspects of life just as much
as the masculine.
Now, you've all been given--
or will be given-- a temporary
tattoo to take away with you.
So even those of you who
don't have permanent ink
can experience what it's
like to be perceived
as a tattooed individual.
And these designs are based on
actual tattoos that I've done.
And I wanted to pick
these in particular
because I feel like as
much as you might want
to try to categorize them
according to, say, the lists
that we looked at or according
to ideas of what tattoos
for men or women
would be, I think
you'd be hard-pressed to assign
a gender to these designs.
I'm just going to finish with
this, one of my favorite--
one of my favorite pictures,
one of my favorite clients.
And I just want to finish--
sorry, I'm so over--
by saying that tattoos
represent such an important way
to portray a greater spectrum
of gender identities,
because we can use imagery
that would not usually
be associated with
our perceived gender
and wear it in a way that
really projects onto the world
our identity and how we
want people to see it.
And the permanence of a
tattoo, the symbolic nature
of the permanence, is
something which says,
this is not a phase.
This is not temporary.
This is a true
expression of who I am
and how I want you to see me.
Thank you.
- Thank you both.
It was wonderful and intriguing.
And the connections with
gender that you finished with,
Dominique, made me think
about that and the permanence
of tattoos, given the
fact that we think
about ways to undermine
that permanence
and that there could
be shifts in our sense
of our own identity.
So I wanted to ask you a little
bit how, in your thinking
and in your practice, you deal
with people who suddenly feel
that a tattoo they had is
something they want to distance
themselves from,
the way they might
about any other
form of embodiment
that they felt was
fixed and anchored?
Of course, I know
you can just go
through the process
of removing them,
but is that part
of your experience?
Or are they stable, and people
say, this is me, like my--
- I think there's a way of--
obviously, certain changes
that we go through in life,
we might like things less
as we get older, especially
the aesthetics of a tattoo.
We might change our mind
about what we like to look at
or, yeah, what
something might mean.
But I think there's
an important lesson
that you can learn
from a tattoo, which
is to maybe just accept and
let go a bit-- like, let
go of the negative
association that you
might have with something
you no longer want.
And just learn to see it
as something that happened,
something you did, and
just kind of let it be.
- Traces of your life.
- Yeah.
You know, we can't--
as much as we might want to
erase certain parts of our life
that maybe weren't the best, we
can't do that, even if we try.
And yeah, if you have a
tattoo of whatever that
was, I think it can help you
just learn to move on from it,
see it differently.
- It comes from
memory, I suppose.
- Yeah.
- Back to gender--
Chandler, I have to confess that
I have been effectively made
to associate scent with gender.
So the first one for me was
like walking in a forest.
I loved it, but I could imagine
wearing it, but also smelling
it in a male body.
Second one, to me, was female.
And does that mean my
connection with my brain
has been definitively
colonized by--
- Marketing.
And so, the first one
for you was masculine.
The second one was feminine.
How about the third--
- No, the second
I could barely--
- Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
The first was feminine,
the second was masculine--
that's what you said, right?
And the third?
- The third-- no, the second
I had a hard time identifying.
I couldn't smell it.
It was so-- it was, indeed,
like minimalist music.
- You couldn't smell
it, or you didn't--
- No, I had a hard--
I mean, this is my sensorium.
I'm sure that I have
some smelling handicaps.
But the third one, to
me, had a very gendered--
- Which gender?
- Female.
OK, the first one?
- Mm, both, but
more male, perhaps.
- More male, OK.
And the second one, you
just couldn't perceive.
- Very, very lightly.
- That's interesting, OK.
- And so what happens,
I find, with smell,
of course, as Proust has
taught us and many others,
is that it has profound
and direct evocations.
- Right.
- So.
- So, this is-- so, fascinating.
OK.
So, first of all, the first
one, which you perceived as more
masculine, is Black Orchid.
It was creative
directed by Tom Ford.
And Tom is one of the
great creative directors.
And that fashion has
colonized, also, perfume.
Perfume was never associated
with fashion until--
oh, God, what was her name?
Coco Chanel was second
and is more famous,
but there was a designer
before, who was a woman.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- What's that?
- Paul [INAUDIBLE].
- No, he was a perfumer.
This was--
- Thinking of a fashion--
- Oh, yes, Poiret.
Paul Parquet was his perfumer.
Yes, but he was not the
first, I don't think.
Fougere Royale was him?
My god, I'm forgetting this.
Anyway, I'm forgetting
these things.
So the first one was
created by Tom Ford.
Black Orchid was launched--
its marketing was absolutely
the quintessence of feminism--
femininity.
So it's supposed to
be a feminine perfume.
But this is what's interesting--
again, you never had this.
And you know what
culture has never
been touched by this marketing?
Arab culture.
And they sell in Arab countries.
It is exactly 50/50.
- That's great.
- And what's interesting,
though, that even in the West,
and with this aggressive--
this woman who was
a friend of Tom's,
and he had her resemble
this sort of thing,
and she wore this thick
lipstick and very much
sort of 1930s film goddess.
It still-- they sell a huge
amount to men, which really is,
I think, a triumph
of the actual work
over the packaging, the
marketing, the presentation.
OK?
The second one, which
you couldn't smell--
it's one that was
creative directed
by Dries van Noten, the
designer, and Frederic Malle.
Beautiful, minimalist-- thank
god Frederic does not gender.
It's one of the geniuses.
I mean, he's an extraordinary,
extraordinary creative
director.
The concept of the works
that he commissions
as the patron of this art
from these great artists,
he has never gendered.
It's extraordinary.
And good for him, OK?
I think that it
has been perceived
as being more masculine.
Again, it's ridiculous.
I don't know.
I'm very interested.
What percentage of you perceived
it as masculine and feminine?
Masculine?
Feminine?
OK.
Now-- yeah.
So fewer people feminine,
and there's definite--
it definitely skews masculine.
You do understand that--
everybody in this room,
I'm sure, understands-- that
that is something that has been
imposed on us, in that
you wouldn't look--
I don't know, like Rembrandt--
not Rembrandt, Renoir seems
to be very, very feminine,
incredibly feminine.
- The bodies he
painted, certainly.
- Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
But is that legitimate?
Is he really for women,
and what does that mean?
The third one, En Passant.
- Ah.
- Yes.
So, this one.
And it skews--
you said feminine.
It's not marketed as--
- One or the other?
- It's again Frederic
Malle's collection.
So we had a Frederic
Malle, we had a Tom Ford--
sorry, we had a Tom
Ford Black Orchid,
and then we had a
Frederic Malle minimalist,
and then we had this,
which was the hyperrealist.
I don't know.
Lilac, do you think--
I understand why, because
people associate flowers.
It's associated with
femininity, traditionally,
in this sort of thing.
It smells like-- I
wear it all the time.
It just smells great on a guy.
- Well, now I guess
I see hands going up.
May I ask anybody
who asks a question
to line up and stand in
front of the microphone?
And please identify yourselves.
And if I may, given the
interest, ask brief questions.
Please go ahead.
- Hi, my name is Zakira.
I wanted to address the
scent as an art work idea.
I think that's
important, because scent
is one of the-- probably the
strongest sensory things.
We remember things of scent
going way back to our childhood
and stuff.
I'm actually
allergic to perfume,
so for me, it's almost
like getting hit
in the nose with a sledgehammer.
So this analogy to, like,
music is interesting to me,
because I wonder if
someone listens to the Sex
Pistols and gets that
same visceral illness
that I sort of feel.
But you would think
I'd be anti-scent.
It's actually contrary.
I think it's-- it's something
I think about a lot.
And I'm just wondering if there
are scent artists out there
that do things that are more
subtle, because for me, it's
like someone carrying around a
boombox at, like, 110 decibels.
- Right.
- It's sometimes offensive.
- But how did you
proceed the second scent,
the minimalist scent?
- I didn't actually--
I was scared, so I
actually moved to the back.
- Well, try it.
I mean, it's extremely quiet.
It's very, very quiet.
It's like one of the
gymnopedie by Satie.
Don't-- I mean, do you
understand why I would say
that?
I mean, it's just--
I think it's much quieter.
Black Orchid is--
I hate to use the word
violent, but it's just--
- Intense.
- Huge.
- Yeah.
- I don't think int--
yeah, but I mean, it's--
- That's number one?
- Sort of, but it's just--
yeah, the romanticists'
work is gigantic.
There's a reason I
say Rachmaninoff.
So it covers you.
It overwhelms you on purpose.
That's the style.
Try the second one.
- OK.
- Try the Dries van Noten.
- Thank you.
- My name's Ari.
My question is for Dominique.
I'm pretty heavily tattooed.
Most of them have
been done by men,
and they've been
great experiences.
But the act of getting a
tattoo is super vulnerable.
It's also really transactional.
And so I'm curious
if you could speak
to what you feel the ethical
obligations of tattoo artists
are to their clients.
- Well, that's quite
an interesting topic.
There's actually-- within
the tattoo community,
there's been very
much a movement,
similar to the MeToo
movement that's
happening, where a
lot of women have been
coming forward and having
had quite awful experiences
with male tattooers.
And people are starting
to really call out
this behavior, because I think
there has always been quite
an imbalance due to the real
masculinization of tattooing
and that the men
behind tattoos, they
see it as something that is
very strong and very, very
masculine.
And so they kind of play
on that quite a bit.
And the experiences
that a lot of people
have-- and I'm not just
talking about the more
extreme and quite
offensive experiences--
but even just being
in that environment,
it can be quite an
oppressive and quite scary
environment because of this
sort of toxic masculinity
that arises quite often in it.
And I think what we are
seeing these days with,
definitely, the rise of the
number of female tattooers
and prominent women within
the tattoo community,
is that is shifting now.
And it's becoming much more of
a experiential process, where
I think people understand
that, like you say,
it's a very vulnerable position
you're putting yourself in.
There's a lot of
trust from both sides.
And I think this realization
that the trust has to be there
and the experience has to be a
positive one is really changing
the way that tattoos are being
done and tattooers are working
and people are getting
tattooed, I think.
Did that answer your question?
I think I rambled, sorry.
- Thank you.
- Hello, my name is Susan.
I'm from the public and greatly
appreciate the Institute
and being able to be here.
So I'm inviting a
reflective comment.
I had an experience here.
And so I wanted to share that.
I kind of deconstructed
it inside myself.
So it relates to shared
space of speaker and listener
as it relates to communication,
both nonverbal and verbal,
as it relates to gender, as it
relates to embodied response.
OK.
This relates to Mr. Burr.
Speaker, listener,
and activation.
OK.
So when the speaker
jumped onto the stage,
I was like, oh my god.
I'm engaged.
I'm anticipating.
I'm there.
Then the speaker
says, ready guys?
And my embodied response is
an immediate abrupt split.
In that split, I knew
I was not invited
into the space as a listener.
So with that split, I
slightly removed myself.
I slightly put a
layer of defense.
Yet I could listen
through the defense,
but I knew I couldn't
fully engage.
- And now I have to maybe
create more distance
by just minding the time.
But thank you.
Thank you.
- Hi, my name is Mathis Dupont.
I'm a master's student
at Simmons University.
So for me, part of what
I'm coming up here is--
I'm a trans person, and
both tattoos and perfume
have been a huge part
of my experience.
And so what I'm
curious for you is
the way that both
of these mediums
are able to queer the body
and transform the body
and how that happens--
and if you had anything to
say about the destabilization
of the natural in
your art forms.
- I--
- Yes, I would say
maybe we have time
for one answer and
one more question,
and then I think
we have to close.
- OK.
Do you mind if I answer
this one instead of--
- No, go ahead.
- There's-- I will
say one thing.
When I would go to Fire Island--
I lived in New York
for a long time.
We're in LA now, but
for a long time, when
I was going out to Fire Island.
And of course there are tons
of drag queens on Fire Island
and everybody does drag.
It's really fun.
And my friends-- I was
at the Times at the time.
And I would meet
these drag queens
who were friends of mine,
people I didn't know.
I would say, well, how--
you're totally incomplete.
What perfume are you wearing?
And they would sort of
go, [GASPS] oh, my god,
I never even thought of this,
because it is so obvious when
you think about it.
And then there was what perfume,
you know, should I wear?
Obviously, Organza for you.
I had one of them wear--
I mean, I can't even
remember them right now.
But they all felt-- they all
started wearing their perfume.
Because drag queens tend to have
a personality that they create.
They would get one, and it would
be part of their presentation.
And they came to
see it as absolutely
essential to the
presentation of the feminine
as it is both represented--
- Coded, yeah.
- And it is subverted
and this sort of thing.
But it became part of that
that was integral to them,
and I loved being part of that.
- Last question, I'm afraid.
- I have a question.
I have a question about
words used as tattoos
and whether there are some
differences between men
and women.
When we talked last night,
I told you about that tattoo
at the Kinsey Institute
over a man's penis that said
[SPEAKING GERMAN].
Very homophobic--
"only for the ladies."
And I wonder what
kind of words do you
see people choosing to
tattoo on their bodies?
- Thank you.
- What sort of words?
Oh, that's interesting.
- A lot of times
it's characters.
They're taking them from
Chinese or Japanese.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I think, actually--
yeah, the trend
in the late '90s, early 2000s
for, especially, Japanese kanji
and things like that.
Yeah, there was a real split,
a definite split and a very
predictable one, I think.
Men would be getting "strong"
and very powerful kind
of words, whereas
yeah, for women it
would have been things
that really represented,
I don't know, beauty or
their appearance in that way.
But I think that that trend
has very much been and gone.
I don't think it really--
I think these days with the
words that people get tattooed,
it just tends to be
very aspirational stuff.
You know, people
want things that
represent their family or
their strength-- in terms
of their personality, rather
than aesthetically speaking.
I think it-- yeah, there
has been a real shift.
And I suppose it's become a
bit more neutral in that sense.
- That's very interesting.
I just realized
when you were saying
that-- if I were ever
going to get a tattoo,
I would get words.
I would never get an image.
- But you would--
- I had never thought about
that until this moment.
I would absolutely get words.
- Yeah.
- Remember that.
- Interesting.
I'll remember that.
- All right.
- I want to thank
Dominique and Chandler.
Very good.